I'm Renaldo Lemos, I'm the director of
the Institute for Technology and Society
of Rio de Janeiro and we're just at the
end of the Artificial Intelligence and
inclusion seminar that just took place
in Rio. And for me the most important
thing that we discussed is "what is the
impact of artificial intelligence over inequality?"
So it seems like artificial intelligence is going to be a game in
which the winner takes it all, so the
question is, who's going to be the winner?
Is it the United States? Is it China? So
does that mean that a lot of resources
are going to flow to those two countries,
and what does it mean for the entire
geopolitical repercussions of that. Number one thing is to invest in science.
I think developing countries have to take science as a priority.
We cannot afford not to participate in these debates.
Second thing is to invest in education. So training people for new skills is also extremely important
in a moment in which there's a lot of possibilities of job insecurity
and transformations in the job market. So
these are the new forms of
infrastructure. The infrastructure of the
future will be investing in people.
Tthat's the way that it will actually
prevent a lot of the bad effects that
Artificial Intelligence might have. In
Brazil we have the Marco Civil law
which is a bill of rights for the
internet, and basically what it does it
regulates from fundamental rights online.
So I think that can be a good
inspiration for artificial intelligence, especially because the process in which
it was built was a collaborative process.
We call it a multi-stakeholder process,
and I think that's the best way to build
public policy regarding technology, when
all sectors of society actually have a
say in the outcome of regulations.
So I think that this experience that
Brazil has had with the Marco Civil
can actually inform in terms of process
how we should deal with challenges, for
instance like artificial intelligence,
and the policy issues that is going to bring.